that's like
oh my gosh I cannot believe that's crazy
someone that can make that amount of
money in a shorter period of time like
somebody who would say a musical artist
right a music producer somebody who's in
entertainment somebody who's on a TV
show somebody who does like concerts and
tours that amount of money isn't the
same to them you know what I mean
what do you mean like say I was dating
somebody like a to do easy right okay he
makes 150 000 minimum per show minimum
that's what he makes in a show yeah so
if he does a couple shows the 200 Grand
to him he won't even feel it now let me
let me show you g-eazy's ex-girlfriend
let me just because she she said G-Eazy
hey asleep
this is who she's talking about if she
was today a G-Eazy that's his
ex-girlfriend
I know that like the raw I know like the
the like that's not a good look like the
way she dresses but like she's stunning
like that is a stunning girl and you you
think you're yeah he's not even he's is
he a star yeah he's a star that's what
I'm saying I'm saying like he's not even
huh
yeah yeah but I'm saying that guy can
get girls like that you're not gonna
have the same results what would you
want huh this is something coming from
someone like I've been in a relationship
with a guy that was worth over a million
like I I but I would never know you
should spend 200k on a ring
like to me that's like that's almost
like entitled like I'm not entitled to
his money I mean
here's the thing I can afford it myself
I I would want you to be able to get it
for me right yeah get it myself
wow oh my gosh that's just
yeah I guess like we kind of probably
have different like spending habits
because to me I'm like I would even if I
had the money I would never spend that
on a ring
like this is she's serious she's dead
serious but I'm also not that much of a
jewelry person right so it's like you're
not gonna need to be buying me diamonds
for every anniversary or jewelry all the
time like get me my ring
and that's it I don't really need much
help
hi oh gosh sorry
hi Nikki I just added you to it
purposely not putting your camera on get
me
I mean if you spend you spent 200
calories I hope I don't he gets you
nothing ever again 200k like what the
[ __ ] you don't you know I don't if you
want something by yourself love if you
can't buy yourself why are you gonna
expect somebody else to buy for you 200k
ring
hook up
no I have to like connect it to the
thing hold on I've done like a YouTube
live with her she's far
oh well
we'll go in a minute sorry
I can I can drop you if this is a bad
time I just thought I'd add you to the
chat no just real quickly because we got
dinner and lamb and all this other good
stuff listen this I love this live this
is hilarious
because I love you but the girls are
asking for 300K diamond rings and
everything on this floor these guys are
now saying that women hit the wall at
age 20. and you're talking about the two
hundred thousand dollar examine they'll
be like oh God
but you guys are both women they're both
women so you really don't know
no but like being around is being just
like a lot of these men they seem like
they're in la la land ourselves and it's
like the people that they're talking
about is like who are you meeting so if
two people are coming with completely
different expectations and like when you
were saying earlier you have pointed out
the person that was in the yoga class
she had a 300 000 ring the person your
coach she has a 300 000 ring it wasn't
like based the reason the ring that I
have I wanted it because of the fact
that growing up some there's no certain
type of thing in my family that that's
what it was but it wasn't because any of
my friends had that ring I couldn't care
less what they had so no I don't want it
because they have it I know I can have
it because they have it do you
understand what I'm saying like I
understand that oh
200 000 eight carat diamond engagement
ring
the grass because I've seen it
I associate with people who have these
things they're in my Circles of people
they're in my friend groups
and I know I can have it because I've
seen it not it's not that I wanted
because they have it I want it and then
I've seen it I've seen validation of it
in my in front of my face I've seen
Buckle them pelvis
I've seen back of them Palace that means
I can go and live there because I've
seen it
well and she showed me this girl like
the girl she's talking about was hot she
was stunning I'm like I'm sorry but she
obviously thinks that she's as hot as a
girl hotter now what's up because she's
gonna get more expensive for me
well I'm not saying that you you
shouldn't want it because I do know
people that they've dreamed about a
certain type of specific wedding since
they were children guys stop screwing
girls like this
we need to stop screwing girls like this
because it's gassing up the EGO some of
y'all are part of the problem because
somebody's taking her out on dates yeah
somebody's pulling her head with this
rubbish would you like to take a picture
of me you know let's have gold you know
gold sprinkled on your food and that's
what's making her happy but can oh my
God I wonder she can cook I don't think
maybe because she eats out a lot
oh she actually could cook it a little
bit I I met her in person once she could
decent yeah like I was the time I was
there she made snacks she can't cook I
won't get rid of that but the attitude
is I think
but I on the other hand I couldn't care
less so there was I I definitely
understand that and especially when it
does come time for people to get married
where people like oh why would you spend
this money why I'm like I don't care
that's that person's prerogative if
that's what they want that's what they
want so if you're saying you see that
because of the fact that you see it on
the everyday person that you communicate
with so you knowing that it's something
that's accessible so if that's that
thought process okay but I don't know
I'm just saying like I think you're
looking for like a one percent guy which
is very rare and I think you're gonna
like
like you're gonna Overlook a lot of guys
that literally make that amount of money
would like have that money to spend but
choose not to because their values are
to save money like that's what I'm
saying like you would Overlook like my
dad in this situation who's like top
half a percent but your Dad's getting
your mom to pop out 10 kids I'm not
trying to pop out there
because my dad wanted her too
remember who you're talking about height
so it I didn't even know I thought most
guys phone call like over six foot so
then when the you know different people
are sharing oh well this is the percent
of these type of I didn't even know that
was a thing because I'm like most guys I
know are pretty tall so now you're
adding the height to 200 000 ring plus I
don't know girl
I know when the universe knows
well at least your options are open
you're not just trying to just outside
of the hype you're open to dating you
know every not everyone I'm just talking
to this guy who doesn't even have a
headboard he has a bed in one pillow and
I said where's your headboard he goes oh
I'm just a regular guy I said oh I
didn't say I don't want to talk to you
anymore I said okay
okay so okay so did I misunderstand
you're okay with like not getting that
stuff
that's just Sheena what how did she know
I was even a studio apartment after she
know that he's got no headboard do you
know I mean she's just if you close your
eyes and listen to her you'd think it
was a a primary school child I mean you
think she's 15. she sounds weird
mentally okay like excited like I'm
gonna get this and I'm gonna